l'information est d'importance elle nous
vient de chine la souche mortelle du
virus de la grippe aviaire a été détecté
chez les porcs il s'agit là du scénario
le plus noir que redoutaient les
scientifiques car le risque de
transmission à l'homme devient plausible
à cette inquiétude s'en ajoute une autre
la chine a gardé cette information pour
elle depuis un an sauf irriguer tout
doit être désinfectée depuis quelques
jours le virus de la grippe aviaire a
fait son apparition en malaisie pas
question de prendre le moindre risque
les élevages de poulets et de canards
sont systématiquement des contaminés et
en cas de doute les animaux abattus sur
place
nous avons bon espoir d'être débarrassé
dans les trois semaines qui viennent de
cette épidémie de grippe aviaire
mais selon les experts il y a de quoi
être inquiet car pour la première fois
la souche mortelle du virus de la grippe
du poulet a été découverte chez des
porcs ce qui est important avec les
cochons c'est qu'ils peuvent tolérer à
la fois le virus animal et le virus de
la grippe humaine
ces virus peuvent se mélanger puis muté
est infecté plus facilement lors si le
virus mute
il pourrait alors provoquer une épidémie
de l'ampleur de la grippe espagnole de
1918 20 millions de morts à la frontière
entre la malaisie et la thaïlande
chaque voiture et contrôlées pour éviter
la propagation de la maladie
en cas d'épidémie il faudrait quatre
mois au moins pour fabriquer un vaccin
efficace